we recently saw vladimir putin uh he was
in like a meeting and he was talking
about uh essentially claiming checkmate
on the global economy and he was saying
that uh when russia invaded ukraine that
was the end of the us dollar dominance
on a global basis and we now are headed
towards a multi-polar world and i'm
always careful to point out
i don't agree with most of what he's
probably done uh and i no way do i want
to seem supportive of that specific
individual or his actions but i do think
that time and again he has continued to
talk about the macro economy in a way
that appears to be more honest or a
different viewpoint than what we hear in
the mainstream media in the united
states of america and so his argument
was the financial sanctions prove to the
world that you have to be friends with
the u.s in order to continue to be
using the u.s dollar system right or
they could kick you out freeze you take
your foreign reserves all this stuff
how much do the sanctions specifically
play into the inflation that we're
seeing because we're now a couple of
months after right there was this talk
uh maybe back in like march i think is
when we first heard the biden
administration say you know putin uh gas
hike and the sanctions and and kind of
the actions but they had only invaded in
like the end of february so it was
unlikely that you were really going to
get kind of price impact for something
that was only existed for two weeks
now we're three four five months later
it feels like now actually there could
be price impact
but i don't know how to think about that
like how do you think through
sanctions
uh geopolitical conflict and then like
we have this super high inflation how do
you unpack how much of it is
contributing to the inflation
oh that's a loaded question my friend uh
so i'll try to
address the various components so
you talked about sanctions like one i
think you and i spoke about this in
recent episodes which is you know when
you go back and look at where inflation
was in january of 22 uh you know prior
to russia it's crossing one border
ukraine you know we were at seven point
five percent and now we're at six or
nine point one percent again year over
year for the month of june so if you
assume russia added all that inflation
you know maybe they've added you know
let's call it 260 basis points of
inflation um that's or sorry how much
baseball is inflation that's that's
that's
that's obviously russia has not caused
all that inflation so there very clearly
is a legitimate inflation problem in the
u.s economy again we just spent five
minutes talking about how the labor
market is overheating by a double that
is generating a for lack of a better
word a crap ton of inflation um
domestically and that's further
supported by uh core services inflation
being at eight percent russia has very
little to do with our services inflation
our housing bubble that the fed and the
fiscal government um before effectively
uh created uh in the pandemic era um but
going back to the sort of um you know
the specific impact of inflation's i
think it's really difficult to sort of
draw a one-to-one like what these are
very dynamic like impossible to model
ecosystems right like one it's almost
like the butterfly fleck
to some degree but one thing we can sort
of do is sort of a cross-sectional
analysis to sort of understand kind of
the relative impact of something like
sanctions right we'll never be able to
know what the actual true basis point
amount of sanctions are but we can look
at something like
the spread between u.s inflation
relative to the rest of the developed
world's inflation and right now if you
factor in the most recent print we're
somewhere around uh you know 160 170
basis points higher than the rest of the
world's developed world the western
world uh inflation rates um that's in
the 95th percentile of all readings
going back as far back as we can get the
data you know you know 50 60 70 years
and so it's telling you that there are
inflationary pressures in the u.s
economy that are very much separate and
apart from things like sanctions etc
which are obviously impacting everyone
at the same time